in the the TV coverage I arrived at work
at about 25 past 9:00 and we had a
meeting in the BMA and as was unusual
custom we caught up with the news and as
we turned on we heard about these power
surges that were going on and actually
the six of us looked at each other we
said we kind of thought this doesn't
seem right this just didn't feel right
and within minutes of that there was
this massive thud and that's what it
felt like a thud with smoke and and the
windows shattering and at the same time
we we can't run for cover within the
room under the desk the the building was
evacuated
we felt it wasn't safe for us to move
from where we were so we stayed and as
the dust settled momentarily
we all went towards the exit and we saw
what was going on I mean I went to look
that check on my staff but in passing we
saw the bus in the chaos and so we were
straight into that courtyard some
colleagues were already outside at the
scene of the bus and within moments what
happened was people started walking
through the arch at the BMA into our
courtyard and we met them and then
others were brought him in with with
lots of injuries and it took a while to
get organized that we had no equipment
at the BMA building doctors ironically
even that was building full of docs is
not hospital hospitals the big green
thing down the road and we we were
improvising and so of the staff and
there was some unused tables and we used
those as stretchers brought people in
one of my colleagues Peter Holden took
command he was a basics and emergency
doctor until the emergency services
arrived we were providing comfort TOC
and obviously first aid to those victims
and the work those that were milling
around walking in
the next thing that happened eventually
supplies started to arrive and trickle
in and we were able to manage those that
were wounded much more effectively made
a huge difference the people there